Aion welcome we're here today with ayaan
Hirsi Ali she's the author of nomads
from Islam to America and we're gonna
talk about your book first let me begin
with asking you why did you write this
book thank you very much for having me
this book is a sequel to infidel my
memoir that I published in 2007 in the
u.s. it answers questions that were
posed by readers of infidel and during
the promotion some of those questions
were posed to me directly I grouped the
questions that I got from readers into
four sets one question regarding my
family and you know how are things
between you and your family right now
another common question from readers of
infidel both in the US and in Europe was
so tell us about your experience in
America how are you faring now that
you're in America
another question had to do with what I
thought now that I was able to compare
the u.s. with Europe about the
assimilation of Muslim minorities into
European society into American society
and I grouped that into three themes
that I call sex money and violence and
how American Muslims and how European
Muslims are you know what brought up how
America is dealing with it how Europe is
dealing with and finally the question
that all readers ask is assuming that
you are right about your analysis in
Islam what should we do which i think is
a question that is much more American
than European Americans are interested
in solutions you have the problem you've
told us what it is what should we do
according to you and I propose three
remedies at the end of the book where I
call on a strategic alliance between
feminists Enlightenment thinkers and the
churches to invite and engage
and perhaps even converts Muslims into
an alternative form of morality other
than Islam well the book is called
nomads now why Nomad because I was born
into a nomadic culture my grandmother
was a proper nomad the people whose
lifestyle is to move from place to place
in search of greener pastures in search
of oases and I have come to find myself
first of all so that's my grandmother's
life and she moves to the city and when
I am born in Somalia to my mother and my
father and you know in my family the
siblings I reflected back on my life and
thought my goodness it was an only
grandmother who was moving around we are
also moving around plenty I was born in
Somalia lived in Saudi Arabia in
Ethiopia in Kenya in the Netherlands and
now in the United States so I think that
kind of captures my inadvertent nomadism
and even now that I'm in the United
States I make my living from giving
speeches for instance talking to
different audiences trying to get my
message across to different people and
that's entails flying from place to
place in this vast country and again I
find myself leading a nomadic life and
somehow I thought that it captured my
life as it is now well in your book you
do talk about your upbringing and how
your roots have affected your decisions
talk a little bit about that so we can
understand the basis and the foundation
in which your messages in this book have
been formed well first of all I'm a
child of globalization I was born at a
time when large numbers of African
countries had just gotten their
independence while getting their
independence or were independent for a
while and that entailed in Africa in the
context that I was born in and later I
found
places in Asia that there were these
coos despots that's took over power very
quickly and people in that I don't want
to use the word class because we hadn't
reached in Africa the level where we
could call ourselves class but let's say
clans groups of people were either
persecuted or they were persecuting
others and those of us who felt
persecuted by those in power started to
move around
we left our countries of origin and went
to elsewhere and that was easy to do and
that means I had lived or was born into
globalization without even realizing
that that was that I was in a
globalizing world when I hear people use
the word multicultural I think back off
my schooling Muslim girl Secondary
School in Nairobi where we came from all
of us came from different cultures and
we were all in search of a better life
and economic progress but to move from A
to B from country to country from
language to language from hemisphere to
hemisphere seemed just so much more so
much easier and more let's say we took
it more for granted than my
grandmother's generation and then we
come I come of age in the Information
Age so rapid modernization that I think
generations like my mother and my
grandmother somehow Dean got a taste of
it but then grow up in I I'm not just a
child of globalization but I'm also a
child that is intellectually comes of
age after 1989 after the fall of the
Soviet Union why was that the case how
did that impact your life directly it
impacted it directly if we accept
someone Huntington's thesis that there
is a clash of civilizations and that
there is a clash between the west and
Islam in the sense that I was born into
the Muslim civilization as the
in Dubai Huntington and lived it and
breathed it was committed to it was
loyal to it believed in it and left it
and came to the West and did the same
thing lived it breathed it made friends
you know made my future here and was
able as an individual to compare not
just the geographical differences and
not just you know the mundane material
differences but the differences in value
systems and I came to really appreciate
one over the other and I made a choice
and I think that makes it if you're if
you're looking to what is it that
informs how I interpret events today the
events that we are living in in everyday
life that informs it I think more than
anything else the fact that I've been
exposed to both worlds exposed to the
thinking in both worlds and that I feel
that I'm able to compare them and and my
opinions are you know one of many one of
a thousand opinions it it's subjective
it's my opinion but that's how Intel I
interpret facts that and events that we
are living in living history today you
would say that a number of the primary
factors that influenced your thinking
are derived from your being part of and
being influenced by globalization your
being part of a tribe you're also as I
understand it you're also your own
background in terms of your education
and being exposed to multicultural
circumstances would you say that's
that's sort of the foundation on which
your book is derived from and your very
being yes the only thing I would add to
that is that I have been exposed to
different types of education my
grandmother and my mother and my Quran
teachers have given me a different set
of education from what I would you know
what I would call what I would label a
Western education Western education was
in individualism it was in
responsibilities was in a sense of at
not just adventure in going you know
traipsing all over the world but
adventure in for instance into the
unknown science reason that's for me is
what I associated with the West and my
grandmother my mother and my Quran
teachers and preachers educated me in
loyalty to the clan tradition and
loyalty to God and the Hereafter loyalty
to the Prophet Mohammed and following in
his example so I was educated in both
places but the education are radically
different what was the turning point for
you though transitioning from the first
to the second what brought that about
that actual transition well many things
first of all my awareness of an of a
world outside where I was brought up by
being moved from place to place becoming
aware other cultures exist the civil war
in Somalia through a lot of Somalis out
out of Somalia when my father in 1992
decided to marry me off he was informed
by the fact that most Somali men were
poor and that it was a great opportunity
to have a man of our clan our religion
close to us come and ask my father for a
bride so my father was convinced that he
was doing something and something right
for me and what was at play was that he
was acting out of a motive to protect me
while he was gone in the ten years
before I had somehow indirectly absorbed
some of the Western ideas that I got
through Western education in Kenya that
I wanted to lead a different life from
my mother's and that conflict is
something very personal and that and
it's it's internal and in that conflict
I was able when my father arranged for
me to go to Germany and in that
arrangement another client member
offered for me to stay with him while he
prepared the paperwork for me to go to
Canada I took advantage again of the
circumstances of globalization
and of technical progress so that I
could take a train from Bonn to
Amsterdam I had never seen a train
before I got to Germany and I was 22
when I first saw him I could have seen
it there are trains in many places in
Africa but I just wasn't exposed to it
and the whole idea of moving from one
country to another in about three hours
was was enthralling the opportunities
that my parents didn't have it certainly
must have had a tremendous impact on you
but you also clearly I think were very
courageous and your mind was obviously
very open to pursuing new challenges and
new directions
clearly when that door opened for you
the paradox is at that time my courage
was not unique at all I was in the midst
of people from Somalia who were brave
enough to escape the Civil War were
resourceful and were able to depend on
one another and one in a diaspora all
over the world
and most of them were doing what I was
doing they simply took a train or a
plane or a car or they hiked to other
places the only difference is once I
arrived in the West and I was able to
compare those you know the different
ways of life I just took one step
further and decided that I wasn't going
to be torn between the two identities
and the two value systems and that I was
going to make that transition and make a
choice that perhaps is I would say the
only difference that I have had from
instance from the women and men who fled
Somalia and took refuge in our house in
Kenya and who later went off into the
Diaspora in the West let's talk about
education you've already mentioned the
impact of your education in Kenya and
you write about it in the book and
you've mentioned it at the beginning of
our discussion talk more about it
because it's so important education is
really critical in terms of impacting a
person's life whether it be at young
women or young
men and it's one of the themes that you
develop say a bit more about how it is
very critical to have an education and
educational opportunities well I would
first start by pointing out that
education means different things to
different people there are different
education when I compare tribal Islamic
education to Western education even
though within those education systems
there are differences and there are
similarities between the two I have a
feeling that when I'm talking to
Westerners they're assuming when they
use the word education at all times
they're assuming Western education for
instance it was Western and alien to my
mother and my grandmother to be educated
in science in geography in history in
logic in physics you know gone just the
curriculum as you get it in in school
and often I would hear my parents
discuss with one another send my
children to school my father would say
to my mother keep them in school and my
mother would say but then they will get
detached from our clan and from our
religion and she would try to educate us
in something else
so Westerners assume when they say
education what they really mean is
Western education and non-westerners
know that and it's the response to that
and non-westerners sometimes encourage
their children to get Western education
and they do that consciously and some of
them are able to give them a bit of
their old traditional identity that
doesn't interfere with our Western
curriculum some of them rejected
altogether my mother rejected it all
together deep in her heart she told my
father
if you send my your daughters to school
and you keep them in school they're
going to talk back to you they're going
to be rebellious they're going to do
things that you don't want them to
and she was completely right education
Western education made me rebellious
made me talkback made me run away made
me lead my own life so it's very
important for us when we talk about
education to identify which type of
education and which type of education do
we encourage and the education system
that I've come to encourage is that
Western form of Education it's
interesting the roles played by your
parents because most cases but not
always you will have mothers who want to
see their daughters educated fully and
to be able to advance themselves and
have vocational opportunities and make
choices for themselves and at times
we've witnessed in certain societies
where usually the father hasn't always
been that forthcoming but you are
mentioning that in your case your father
was encouraging an educational path a
Western medical Western educational path
but your mother was concerned about what
that would do she was concerned and her
concern was if you educate your children
Western Sal they'll become like
Westerners and move away from our
traditions and from our from our
religion and she was right in that now
they're not all Muslim women are like my
mother not all Muslim families are like
my family
some of them somehow find a
reconciliation between giving their
children a Western education and at the
same time keeping them within the clan
loyalties and within the Islamic
religion the loyalties that is a small
group what I have noticed especially
when it comes to the big question in
Europe of assimilating Muslim minorities
into Dutch society French society
British society where the leadership of
these societies are talking about
Western education that that
reconciliation is not something that you
should be taken for granted it is a very
difficult transition that many
immigrants either
do not know how to go about it or even
if they know how to go about this reject
Western education and somehow just
cannot find a balance between the two
and that is what I find interesting and
I think my life in the story of my life
illustrate those transitional
differences and in Nomad I try to
explain that because individuals are
very different I made the transition my
sister almost made it and then didn't my
brother who was really very good in
school when we were in Somalia in Saudi
Arabia in Ethiopia in Kenya he would get
the admiration of his teachers and
everyone around him in how he performed
academically that is in Western
education that he was getting but
somehow he didn't make it as he grew
older and mature what he got lost in
that hiatus in that gap between the two
cultures I come across other people who
have made it I mean in Washington alone
I come I meet many people from the
Muslim world who have made it an are
stars I mean what a Jamie a man I admire
a lot Fareed Zakaria there are some very
famous names in the United States who
did make that transition I only tell in
normal my story about how I think that I
made it but also why I think it is
difficult for the mainstream to cross
that bridge you also talk about in the
book not only the importance of Western
education but you also talk about this
concept of integration and transition
and three elements that you identify as
being very important you talk about
responsibility duty and critical
thinking talk a bit about that why is
that very instructive for others who may
be pursuing a nomadic life and can look
to your example in terms of the kinds of
transitions that you have made when I
came to the West I realized that words
such as responsibility
where I come from it is responsibilities
to the clan responsibility to God
responsibility to the group and to the
family in the West it was ingrained
responsibility in yourself as an
individual you are you you were brought
up at least by most Western firm that
seemed to be the general idea you as an
individual find your own path in life
and responsibility to others means not
bringing them harm where I come from
responsibility means not giving up on
the habits and rituals and convictions
that the clan gives to you and passing
them on to the next generation duty
means duty to your parents as a child
you are almost an insurance policy for
your parents because when they grow old
you take care of them when I was in
Holland and we talked about my first
line the word insurance it meant that
you made your own money and you saved it
and you took care of your old age and
your parents didn't depend on you they
dependent on themselves you pay taxes
they save pensions etcetera that kind of
system but to be financially responsible
in that way you have to become literate
in the modern way of going about money
and sometimes it involved shedding your
duties and your responsibilities in your
sense of guilt toward your parents who
like one of the cousins that I discuss
in the book every time he makes a penny
a dollar
he sends three-quarters of its to his
father and his father uses that money to
marry more wife's to have more children
because that according to his father
that's how wealth is defined and I worry
about my poor cousin because I think
he's not saving any money he has no
pensions he's worked all this time in
his life and he's going to depend on
welfare and many many Europeans with
whom I have had discussions about how to
eliminate to at least reduce poverty
among immigrants somehow overlooked this
mechanism and look for it in other
factors
just the discrimination of society
against Muslim immigrants Muslims feel
persecuted and discriminated against but
I think these are external factors the
more internal factors the decisions that
we make on a day to day life and what
inspires them I think that's what we
need to talk about and that is the
message of normal and not only regarding
money but also regarding aggression
regarding sexuality in specially
sexuality because that is important in
the position of women in improving the
position of women and if the position of
women is improved I think a great deal
of poverty will be relieved
not only for immigrants in Europe and
America but for any all poor people
worldwide you also discuss in the book
that there are three barriers to
integration and one of them is the
treatment of women let's discuss that
what does that mean exactly and what did
you have in mind in terms of the
specific treatment of women the
treatment of women is related to the
theme that we just discussed sexuality
in clan devout Islamic tribal life the
female is considered to be at her best a
mother and a wife other than that she is
a risky business the owner of the family
lives on high behavior and especially on
her sexual behavior and in a collective
people gossip about one another people
are jealous of one another and the way a
woman behaves that can be the subject of
gossipy and in a society governed by
honor and shame her behavior that is
considered deviant can lead the clans
honor the families on her brother's
honor to be to be smeared reduced
violated the way to deal with it is to
ensure that she is a virgin before her
wedding night and as soon as she is
married that she's
faithful so the education that a gal
gets from a very young age is to be very
chase stay at home be obedient and God
hah virginity when she is married to be
obedient and serving and submissive to
her husband that is enforced in
different ways by different families
some families like mine like my
grandmother and sure that you undergo
female genital mutilation and you are
covered or you stay at home its preached
over and over to you what could happen
to you if you were to violate the owner
of the family in places like Saudi
Arabia the entire society is segregated
into the male side and the female side
including the house including the home
women are covered up they are denied to
go outside the houses without chaperones
the situation in Saudi Arabia I think
most Americans are familiar with I don't
have to describe that now in coming to
Holland the problems that Westerners
like the Dutch and the British and the
Americans are confronted with Muslim
families trying to enforce that vision
of the position of women here in the
United States where women have radically
different rights and are considered to
be equal to their male counterparts and
are considered to be able at adulthood
to choose their own lifestyles make
their own money and have access to
education and in fact it is considered
to be something great and positive to
encourage women to take part in the
workforce etc and there you have a
collision there you have a clash of
civilizations how do you value the
female how do you value the relationship
between men and women what governs that
and that value I can't think of anything
where the west and Islamic countries are
more different in their outlook then the
way women are valued and their
contribution to society how does one
deal with that
you mentioned Samuel Huntington he was
my professor at hard Harvard and his his
writings on the clash of civilization
you have referenced and you do subscribe
to but now how does one deal with it is
there a type of series of actions or
steps that could be taken to deal with
that I would start the series of
assumptions and one assumption would be
if you compare the two value systems
regarding women the Western the Islamic
which one do you consider better if you
assume I do that the Western value
system regarding women is better then we
are consider confronted with the next
step which is do you preserve or allow
these communities to preserve their ways
regarding women or do you refuse to
accept that and I think professor
somewhat Huntington would say on
American soil I don't think he would
propose changing them elsewhere but an
American soil on Western so I think he
would say we we should not practice
relativism there we should protect the
rights of all individuals regardless of
their heritage on American so that
entails a policy that protects the
victims of Islamic culture female
Islamic culture and the punishment of
the perpetrators but also a sustained
education in Muslim men and women to
give up their attitudes toward women and
their practices and their habits and to
adopt new ones where does the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights fit into
this because that provides a standard
for all men and women and the protection
of Human Rights
isn't that and shouldn't that be a
factor in all societies not just one it
is a factor for all societies but it is
an ideal in some places that ideal has
been reached
I think the United States is one of them
I don't think it's perfect and perfectly
round but I think most of what is in the
declaration of Universal Declaration of
Human Rights is actually implemented
in the West it is not in the rest of the
world one can say we are going to
campaign as Westerners outside of the
West for these universal rights and that
campaigning has delivered some results
some countries have signed and ratified
the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights even though they have not
implemented it you can keep pushing for
that what I saw and this is the product
of infidel and Nomad is even in the
United States in the United Kingdom in
Holland in France places where the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights as
far as it regards women has been adopted
and implemented that Muslim women are
excluded from that excluded from the
protection of the law there are Muslim
lobby organizations in Canada in the
u.s. in the UK lobbying for parts of
Sharia to be accepted describe what
Sharia law is I know here in the United
States it much has been written about it
but I'm sure our audience would be
interested in hearing your definition of
Sharia law Sharia law is Islamic law or
law derived from Islam Islam means
submission to the will of Allah was
founded by Muhammad bin Abdullah he
considers himself a prophet and he's
regarded by his followers as a prophet
initially in Mecca he had only preached
an attitude toward humanity and toward
one another of hospitality and charity
etc once in Medina when he fled from
Mecca he went to Ethiopia then called
Abyssinia landed in Medina and once in
Medina
his following became strong enough to
form a militia or militias and from
being a peace-loving peace preaching
prophet he turned into a warrior a
conqueror and at that time when his
following became so large almost as
large as a society at that time he said
that he had laws revealed to them that
must govern that society
and that set of laws that were revealed
to him and their father evolution is
termed Sharia or Islamic law now you
have to imagine those laws in this in
the context of the 7th century and as
they evolved the 8th 9th 10th centuries
the laws governing women and men at that
time were considered to be incredibly
progressive for instance in the context
of that Adam desert culture which was
very patriarchal men were allowed to
have an unlimited number of concubines
he reduced that to four men could leave
women as well he decided that he should
now have a dowry he introduced the law
of banning infanticide in that context
little children girls if they were
considered to be too many were buried
alive
he banned that was very very progressive
at that time but if you take Sharia law
from that time 7th century regarding
women and you apply it now in the 21st
century when countries like the United
States are governed by the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights and women
are equal to men and you disinherit
women they inherit half of what their
brother gets their testimony is worth
half of that of a man they get a so
called dowry that is determined by a
guardian and that is not really what
they want or at least does not serve
their interests that when raped they
have to produce they they have to
testify against the man who raped them
but their testimony is worth only half
all of these things that they have to
have a guardian all of these things that
in the 7th century seemed very
progressive in the 21st century are
really very very reactionary and
detrimental to women and that is my
criticism of sharia let's stop doing
everything as we used to do and look
into the past and trying to revive the
7th century let's look forward and to
Western society to Americans let's not
exclude women from the general law that
applies to all of us on
because they were born into Islam and
only because the perpetrators justify
their actions in the name of religion or
culture now when your book came out and
just recently the New York Times Sunday
magazine had you featured and there were
a series of questions asked in that in
the magazine and it the title of it was
feminist and it was casting you as a
feminist do you view yourself as a
feminist I view myself as a feminist in
the classical sense of the word when
feminists fought for the heights of
women
but these were Heights that were a
matter of life and death and they were a
matter of justice I have encountered
feminists who have a different set of
priorities feminists who feel that we
should all organize ourselves in order
to move in relationships between men and
women whether they are married or not
for the men to do their fair share of
household chores that's very important
but I'm not going to join such a
movement I think if you're intelligent
enough you you will be able to to sort
that out yourself feminists who organize
themselves to open the Gulf all-male
golf tournaments to become female golf
so women can be allowed into it very
laudable but I'm not a part of that I
just don't think it's a priority when
children little girls are denied life
when they're pulled out of school when
they are being killed and there is a
movement or part of the feminist branch
who feel that shattering the glass
ceiling is it's a great priority it's
not my priority when I read about girls
here in the United States who are taken
by their father put in a cab and shot
and run over by their fathers when all
of this is going on and I'm not even
talking about China and India and all
the terrible things that are done to
women and against women and that happens
to Chinese women here and to Indian
women here I think that as feminists we
should rearrange our priorities and
say you know when it comes to violating
the most basic rights of women that that
getting rid of that and addressing that
and fighting that that should be our
priority and that the other parts of it
all very important but very luxurious
just go down on the list the United
Nations had a series of Arab human
development reports and in those reports
there were sections in fact devoted to
women and areas in which women were
denied rights or denied opportunities
especially in terms of voting in terms
of employment do you think that those
kinds of reports can have some impact
have you seen some change because
clearly you're trying to get out certain
messages about the kinds of changes and
the kinds of opportunities you have
several messages in your book but do you
think reports like that where you have a
report that is in fact written by Arab
scholars can be helpful to bring about
change absolutely I know those reports
and I think they're extremely important
in our time because they start with
acknowledging the fact that women are
denied their freedom that large swathes
of Arab Muslim women denied education so
that now in some countries you even have
a 70% illiteracy among women you have
maternal mortality you have child rights
you have forced marriages you have
stonings and killings these these
reports were incredibly important
because they acknowledge that there is
something wrong but I would like to do
with others I am not the only one is to
take that discussion to the next level
not only acknowledge the very despairing
and terrible position of Arab Muslim
women but also acknowledge the causes
that underlie them in my case especially
those that have to do with the
customs the habits the convictions the
religious justifications that are given
for these atrocities so it's not enough
for all of us to come out and say
killing women is bad child brides are
bad but why child brides what is it that
motivates our Father to sell his
daughter to another man for a little bit
of money to every father who has been
questioned he says but the Prophet
Muhammad did it he is my moral guide I
am a Muslim I'm following that guidance
let us then discuss that guidance and
investigated and teach that man
something new
other than that guidance that is the
sort of thing that is in the step that
we have to move and that is the step
that is taboo and it's the most
difficult step because we are talking
about a fourteen hundred year old
religion and tradition and it's almost
set in stone it's not set in stone
things are moving but that is the most
difficult part of it and that is really
what you know where all the work is
going to be you're an advocate clearly
of dialogue and you mentioned at the
beginning of our discussion and it's in
your book about the importance of
dialogue and one of the areas that you
have been engaged in and also trying to
advance as having Christians and
speaking and sitting down with Muslims
and having if you will almost cross
religious discussions and opportunities
to benefit from the experiences develop
that a bit talk about that about your
ideas in that regard that you have
identified in the book and that you are
actually acting on upon well I feel like
in the West if you assume that someone
Huntington's thesis of a clash of
civilizations is correct I think I feel
that in the West we have been cornered
into an attitude of defense we are on
the defensive continues you're always
saying we are we are not Islamophobes we
are not discriminating we lie
q on the one hand on the other hand we
are using military means and spying
methods to deal with jihad and with the
violence against the West against women
etc what I would like us to do is to go
back to the realm of ideas assume that
Muslim individuals are endowed with
reason that if engaged in dialogue and I
mean improper dialogue where you don't
shy away and move around and beat about
the bush in the areas where there is a
real a real conflict of values but
freely address them that there is a
possibility of changing people's minds
just last night I was in Philadelphia
and it was on the heckard a young Muslim
woman stands up with a headscarf and she
challenges me she's from Afghanistan and
she challenges me she says I am born in
Afghanistan and the men in my family
well good to me they sent me to school I
am now in University in the United
States and it's because of the men in my
family I am I dare you to tell me what
what is it about the Koran that you
didn't like and I gave it I told how
well it's chapter 4 verse 34 the verse
that says beats your wife it is chapter
2 verse 222 that gives man permission to
rape their wives in in marriage women
from Afghanistan have protested against
this this was reported I read it in the
New York Times but this was reported in
the West this young woman was sitting
there jotting down those verses she's
going to look them up she's going to
link them I'm not saying that I've
changed her mind or that I've made her
into something else that she is not but
I was so inspired and encouraged by her
curiosity by wanting to know what it was
that I didn't want and I see most Muslim
people as such as that young woman
wanting to know they are a group of them
very elite very privileged living in the
United States I encounter them in
campuses that have this PostScript
narratives that they come with who are
not ready to listen but I just there to
grab the mic and you know do their thing
which is to defend the image of Islam
but they're not speaking for Islam
they're not speaking for Muslims they're
not speaking for this young woman who
wants to know who wants to learn for
whom learning is a grace it's a great
deal and I am sure that if Christians
were to do the same if feminists were to
do the same if Enlightenment thinkers
were to do the same that many many
Muslim minds but are now trapped in this
radical you know born-again Islam this
jihadist form of Islam would change
their minds and adopt new ideas are open
to something else other than following
the example of mohammed are you trying
to put together formal dialogues and
discussions toward that end
you're clearly speaking speaking to
different audiences and targeting some
here and there but in a systematic way
are you thinking about the organization
of these kinds of dialogues maybe with
some of the same people not just once
but several times is that something
that's on your agenda it is on my agenda
but again I believe in putting as a
priority really the most severe forms of
human rights violations I've started the
AHA Foundation which is a short form for
ayaan Hirsi Ali but also the
Enlightenment aha and at the I have
foundation with a number of American
women who said we don't just want to
talk we want to do something and I
pointed out to my experience in the
Netherlands and in Europe where for a
long time these practices of female
genital mutilation and forced marriages
honor killings child brides or going on
in society was looking the other way and
I said I suspect that something like
that might be going on in the United
States and with that foundation first of
all we want to start by informing the
American population that it is here
researching how many you know we don't
have data exactly to how many women as
this happen
and then educating and influencing the
American leadership to prevent these
things from happening and then from
there perhaps the young woman I just
described individuals like that will
emerge and will you know take the
debates themselves to a different level
there was another woman in that
Philadelphia library and he is I think
where dialogue pays off who was wearing
a headscarf
it's a practicing Muslim and said I do
exactly what you do but I only do it
undercover and I and I have you must've
asked her well why undercover I of
course even though I know it because a
lot of the readers of infidel women and
they writes to me and they write to me
about the consequences of what they face
there are they risk being shunned being
vilified character assassination being
beaten and sometimes even being killed
so the price that you pay for this
transition is very very very high and
some of us want to pay that price in our
own different way but we are there we
are there and I think that right now
the loudest voices that we hear others
people who are saying there's nothing
wrong with Islam it has nothing to do
with Islam or those people who are
actively winning hearts and minds or the
muslim community for the jihadi project
let me ask you about your foundation are
you looking at specifically these areas
that you identified in the United States
if I understood you correctly or you're
trying to educate Americans about these
acts against women and these human
rights violations against women
worldwide
oh no I believe in starting small I also
believe in charity begins at home
we are looking at these practices in the
United States and educating Americans in
the fifty states to look at their Muslim
communities and if they see these
practices to recognize it first as
something different and not the general
domestic violence and to do something
about it sometimes perhaps to adjust
legislation sometimes to take girls in
from the streets because sometimes when
you save a guy
from misogyny in her own family's house
she ends up in the streets and gets into
worse trouble and I want American
families to know that there are young
women often very bright and often very
keen to learn who whom they could adopt
and could help and become American and
live the American dream he's trafficking
and one of the issues that's on the
agenda or related to these communities
it is not the agenda of the Hopf
foundation but we work closely with the
Somali mom foundation who's really only
focused on combating trafficking
she's a Cambodian woman Somali mom who
is herself a victim of trafficking and
there are other women's rights
organizations that deal with that but if
we see anything that has to do with
trafficking and I'm sure there are many
Muslim women who are victims of
trafficking we we pass it on to the
organizations that we work together with
what's your recommendation to us policy
makers in terms of the violations
against women women's rights against
also the other aspect of your book in
terms of integration and how one can
help in the assimilation of those coming
to the United States and their
interrelationships here but what what
are your recommendations and how are you
trying to get your views out to policy
makers in Washington what I would like
to say to policy makers in Washington is
where the integration or the
assimilation of Muslim immigrants are
concerned to recognize that Islam has
three dimensions there's the spiritual
dimension of prayer and fasting and you
know that very personal relationship
with one's concept of God I would tell
policy makers to respect that as they
already do so but to also acknowledge
that there are three other dimensions of
Islam as some policymakers already know
one is the political aspect you know we
call it jihadism or salafism
overharvesting but we're young children
young adults
into believing that they are part of an
Ummah that is under siege and that they
have to fight back by whatever means
they can so to be very aware of that
political aspect of Islam and then the
third dimension of us Islam is the
social dimension of Islam and the
emphasis is on the relationship between
men and women but also the treatment of
gay people and if policymakers know that
as a religious group women are
discriminated against them that it's
justified in the name of a religion that
gay people are discriminated against
it's justified in the name of a religion
then policymakers should pay attention
to the plight of the victims take their
side and protect them and probably
educate the perpetrators or the
potential perpetrators on American law
and American culture and the American
value system
have you met with state legislators
members of Congress or members of the
administration to set forth your ideas I
have had superficial meetings
coincidental meetings and conferences
with some people who work for the
administration with some people in the
Senate with some people who are in the
Pentagon during the former
administration I think I've been once to
the Senate I've been to the Pentagon I
write about it but I haven't really you
know sat down and said okay I'm going to
help develop a policy of integration for
Muslims or even of recognizing that
these problems exist in the United
States is that something that you hope
to do in the months in the years ahead
it isn't I would love to contribute to
anything I can in the United States that
will help Americans and and Muslim
Americans become American and it can be
in the following months I work for the
American Enterprise Institute is a
citizenship project there I hope to be
part of you know part of that project in
thinking through the different meanings
of citizenship and how that is
implemented and what that means have you
felt that by writing the book that
you're also sending
message to others like you in different
parts of the world and not just only
from Somalia but elsewhere who are
really grappling with these kinds of
challenges and they're in their lives
and you know if so how do you hope to
follow up with that I am I am doing that
and I'm encouraged by the response from
people in Kenya for instance where I
spent a lot of my life people from India
from Pakistan even from Indonesia and
Malaysia people from Turkey writing to
me after they had read infidel in their
languages and telling me what they think
of it and how they identify with me and
you know informing me about what they're
doing in their own societies I'm
encouraged by that and this book is also
for them and especially for them I think
that persuasion just the idea I'm I'm
always told you are so you know Rosie
I'd about the West you are dazzled by
the West and I want to say I am dazzled
by the prospect of changing one's mind
through dialogue through reason and
through fact-finding and by exchanging
ideas with people that you disagree with
and getting educated and yeah I find
that not only dazzling but it's
something that I'm really grateful for
and I have to say it's very unique to
the West do you keep in touch with the
members of your family and what are they
thinking about about this I describe
that a nomad in detail my father passed
away and just before he passed away he
was trying to convince me to come back
to Islam my conversation with my mother
is it's like a one-way traffic my mother
tries also to do the same thing prevents
me from in her understanding prevents me
from going to hell my half-sister did
exactly the same thing tries to convince
me to come back to Islam I have another
cousin who is much more on my side but
insists that she's still a Muslim and
doesn't really want to give up on the
religion so I have I mean I relate the
stories of
there is just something that you can
never take away when you grow up are
siblings is that familiarity and that
loyalty I'm looking after my brother son
and it's just that you know basic human
relationship that is I think much older
than religion absolutely let me ask you
in the United States many say that when
there are those who come here or of
course a a a country of immigrants and
many have come here with big dreams what
is your big dream what is it that you
hope for myself for yourself and and for
others both well my big hope for Muslims
in general and Muslims in the West and
Muslims in America is for them to shed
the political aspect and the social
aspect of Islam I can live with their
religious dimension I mean if people
want to pray that is fine but by doing
so they don't harm others but to shed
any inspiration they get from Islam to
do harm to themselves or others the big
dream for myself is to lead a life in
freedom and in safety and where I can
spend part of my life
contributing to what I think is the
improvement of humanity would you say
that you're already living that dream
for yourself I'm live at this time I'm
living that dream I'm living it within
the parameters of the security that I
have but I feel that I am living it and
I am really very very grateful to the
American Enterprise Institute that
brought me here and the many American
friends that I've already made who make
me feel every single day that I meet
them that this is a great nation and I
know why it's great and that doesn't
mean it's perfect doesn't mean that
accidents don't happen it doesn't mean
that I think that the oil spill is great
and stuff like that or that the
continuous conflict between the two
parties is great but what as an outsider
as an outsider who has lived in all
these places where political conflict
always ended up in bloodshed what I find
fantastic about the United States is
always
heated debates that always end up
somehow and in a vote that's true that's
true there's always a very heated debate
and an outcome and then once there's an
outcome at least both try to stick with
it no they move to another subject so I
thought the world was going to be
divided by healthcare and now everyone
is talking about the oil spill and when
that is settled then I think we'll move
on to the next subject and let me ask
you finally what is your next book gonna
be on my next book is really the book
that I wanted to write bit before Nomad
and before infidel it's called shortcut
to enlightenment it is about the Prophet
Muhammad coming back to life in the New
York Public Library and meeting Karl
Popper and discussing with him the
difference between the open society and
the closed society him meeting with
Friedrich Hayek and discussing with him
you know individualism versus
collectivism Muhammad is going to defend
collectivism Hayek is going to defend
passionately individualism and Muhammad
will also talk to John Stuart Mill
another man who is going to defend the
equality between men and women and
Muhammad is going to defend his take on
why women should be subordinate to men
that is the next book
well I on here say Ali thank you for
coming today
and we're looking very much forward to
your next book thank you very much